Uh,
I guess we have to say that too.
Yeah.
Obviously it's a ridiculous time and,
and like everyone's been saying again,
you know what I mean?
It's like,
here we go again.
Another again,
another mass shooting.
And that the,
I think the most disturbing graphic to me was the scorecard.
Like they showed like this guy got 58 and then the guy in Orlando got what?
40 something.
And so because it's like,
okay,
you just encouraged the next cycle to try to set the record,
you know what I mean?
Like it,
like it shouldn't be,
there has to be another way to say it without giving publicity to he killed more
than anybody else,
you know?
Well,
for everybody's listening to them,
the future,
this is taking place.
We're recording this on Tuesday.
Uh,
the massacre happened in Las Vegas on Sunday,
so it's just a couple of days ago.
And,
uh,
we were just going over all the details of it.
I'm,
I'm reading online here,
killed 59 people injured 527,
which is just fucking completely insane.
I mean 527 people shot.
Is that right or is that like,
does that count?
People trampled?
I think it,
it includes people trampled in injured otherwise,
but there were a hell of a lot of people shot.
I mean,
he opened up with automatic weapons into a crowd of thousands of people to where
probably,
you know,
did any bullets hit the ground?
Like there were so many people,
if this thing that every bullet probably hit somebody,
you know,
or more than one person depending,
I don't know the,
the power of the ballistics of the a weapon,
but,
oh yeah,
he,
you know,
it definitely like bullets could have went through one guy into that
Mac hunter since I'm sure they did.
I'm 100%,
um,
this guy,
first of all,
there's a,
you know,
everybody's a,
it's becomes a big gun control argument,
which it should be.
Right.
But,
uh,
one thing that we got to really take into consideration,
he had an illegal guns.
These guns were illegal,
I think for 25 years.
So this isn't,
um,
I don't know how much of this could have been helped by making it more legal.
Yeah.
It,
it,
you know,
that's always the debate first.
The first problem is what was going on yesterday when they say this is not the
time to talk about guns.
And it,
it,
yeah,
of course it's the exact time to talk about guns and,
and,
and I'm not a gun guy in the sense that I'm not a gun owner,
but I get it with guys who are into guns.
I always compare it to my love of cars and bikes or,
you know,
anything mechanical or whatever.
I understand it,
but,
but the people,
most of the people I talk to who love guns don't have a problem with like
registration certainly don't have a problem with education and,
and what I call common sense gun ownership and that there's some guns that I get
it,
you want,
there are some guns that,
you know,
and again,
I'm not speaking with any expertise,
but from the layman's point of view,
it's like,
why do you need this semiautomatic military style weapon?
And,
and,
uh,
you know,
don't tell me you have it for hunting or anything else.
Like if there's a reason you want to collect it,
just like if there's a reason you want to own a race card,
right?
And somebody says,
why do you need a car that does 200 miles an hour?
Well,
you may have a reason you want that race car,
but you don't use it on the street.
You can't take it,
you know,
onto the streets and that,
and I think that should be that there should be some kind of rule with that kind
of weapon,
that event.
Here's the thing,
it doesn't matter if there's a rule.
This guy,
there were plenty of rules.
Yeah,
that guy violated all the rules that this guy did.
But I'm just talking about the general attitude towards sales.
Just the idea that you can walk into a store and buy these weapons.
Yeah.
It should somehow be more difficult to,
you know,
and again,
this is my opinion,
right?
But I think it should be more difficult to buy a weapon of that tight.
Yeah.
Well,
these are all illegal weapons.
This guy,
this guy,
he converted them to fully automatic and fully automatics illegal everywhere.
Right?
Here's what's fucked up about this guy.
This guy didn't have a criminal record.
He had no army training,
no religious or political affiliation affiliations.
No one has any idea what his motives were.
He was wealthy.
He's a big time high roller,
which is how he got this giant suite in Vegas.
I mean it is fucking bizarre.
Did you see his brother get interviewed?
Yeah.
Yeah,
and,
and it's,
well,
it's,
that's the one thing about this,
that's the thing about this kind of insanity,
right?
There is usually no outward.
Like,
like how many people are like this in this country that we don't know about?
You know what I mean?
That have as particularly if you're wealthy,
if you're wealthy,
it's so much easier to hide it,
right?
Because you may have a big house,
you may have a compound,
you may have a,
you know,
a camp,
a place you go camping in the woods that's actually stocked with a,
you know,
a hundred weapons or something like that.
I mean that the randomness of this,
to me that is the biggest horror.
The worst thing about this to me is just the idea of like you went to a fucking
concert,
right?
Like that's all you did.
You went to a concert in Vegas and you're never coming home.
Your family's destroyed everything.
I mean,
and,
and that is the utter randomness of it that you can't control.
Well,
that's what's terrifying about it.
This is,
which is really strange to me,
the definition of terrorist.
Nobody's calling this guy a terrorist.
Like what do you have to be like political or religious to be a terrorist?
Like how the fuck I'm not a terrorist?
Yes,
this is definitely terror.
This is definitely terror because the unit,
you know why it's terrible because now are you going to go to a big event in
Vegas?
Are you going to go to a big outdoor calm?
You know,
Vegas does these music festivals in front of sees these towers,
right?
And then someone could do something like this and the,
and the pools,
you know,
they have those giant Edm parties at pools all summer that are literally
surrounded by the Tower of whatever hotel you're in.
So net.
So that's why it's terror because now you have to be afraid to do that.
Well,
not only that,
like this,
now they're going to have some sort of screening when you go into hotels,
which by the way,
why the fuck didn't they have them already?
How I've always thought this,
like the airports are so stringent.
Like you go through the airports,
they check your deck.
They literally will pat your Dick if you hit a random,
you know,
being,
I'm sorry sir,
we got to check your day,
your random,
and they literally put the back of their hand.
This was a really odd to me that it's okay to touch your Dick with the back,
back of your hand.
It's like the less sensitive they get to see me.
They get to smooth it down.
But that's so weird.
Like it's okay sir.
I'm just using the back of my hand and touch your Dick.
Like they might have had,
they might have had them grabbing and some guy was just like,
I'm not grabbing a hard dick.
Yeah,
there's no doubt it was dumb.
They get down you the other guy,
like I'm not getting my dick hard by some guy who's looking for a weapon.
It's just weird that they can do that.
But if you go to the airport,
right?
Like airports we've decided are places where terror exists.
Right?
So you have like,
like I have a TSA pre and I have a
oh global entry guy and all of that have a clear,
clear is the best.
Clear is the best way.
Fingers it,
right?
Yeah.
Would it have it?
He just put your fingers,
Bam.
It's got a picture of you go right through.
It takes two seconds,
right?
Yeah.
But that's just a place where we've decided you have terror.
Right.
And now are we going to decide that you have terror everywhere?
No,
I don't think so.
I mean,
for one thing I,
I'm,
I'm not buying into the hotel argument.
Like there's a bigger issue here,
then the hotels and the issue is the weapons.
And what can we do about the prolific,
uh,
the collation of weapons?
Proliferation.
Proliferation of weapons?
Yes.
Sorry about that.
You started,
where did you go?
Oh,
I'm too deep into this word.
I got too deep into a word now there's no backing out all the damn weapon.
No,
but that,
but that's the issue.
The thing about hotels though,
and this being the United States,
the privacy issue is huge,
right?
You're a hotel room is basically your home away from home.
When do you get,
what other privacy rules of checking what you bring into a hotel?
What's in your hotel room room?
Remember the,
um,
the stoplight cameras,
right?
Yes.
And they got sued and people got in trouble because they got that picture taken
and the wrong person was in their cart.
Write that check.
Wasn't his wife.
Yeah.
Or this guy wasn't as husband.
One guy sued because he,
the picture was taken.
The woman wasn't his wife.
They send the ticket to your house.
Right?
He got into a,
yeah,
exactly.
And,
and he won the suit in the sense that you're,
there's a level of privacy that's expected in your car.
Do you understand why that it's illegal though.
Cause it's,
it's a third party.
It's not actually even the government.
Right.
They farmed it off some other company that's sending you a ticket and charging
you money.
Right.
Well and everybody was like,
well what do you,
you guys are having your hiring people to do this commissioning.
Yeah.
A place to write tickets they had to do,
they had to rename the cameras to only hit the license plate.
But that's not true.
Cause I got one the other day and just showed you and sent me a picture of me
smiling.
Well it's not a little cocky.
Tried to go right on red and it flashed me.
But,
but the point being in your hotel room like this,
an expectation of privacy and,
and where is that line drawn?
The other one's going to have to be drawn in Vegas Cause people get freaky in
Vegas.
Right.
The other big difference,
and I'll tell you a Vegas story about that.
That's great.
I heard,
but the other big difference is when you're on an airplane,
your trapped in that airplane when you're in a hotel like you can run.
You know what I mean?
You can run down the stairs.
You really know you compared to being in an airplane.
I don't think it's a valid comparison,
honestly.
I mean it's like you're still in a box.
You're still,
you're in it,
you're in a confined space.
But I think it's easy to escape.
Now the thing about about Vegas,
this guy told me who was a security guy,
he said the thing about the cameras is you,
you see who's with who and that there was one particular guy that kept seeing
but he kept bringing transgender hookers to a girl and like they knew who he
was.
He was like a famous guy and they were like,
yeah we can,
we could destroy this guy if we wanted.
We got,
cause they got cameras everywhere in Vegas.
Right.
They know who's coming upstairs,
right room.
They know what room they're going to get.
Like super obvious transgender ones like yeah,
like the giant football player
guys.
You felt like you dresses on.
So,
uh,
you know,
so I had to give up that hobby.
No,
I'm kidding.
That's the only thing from this podcast.
It's going to go out viral.
We knew it.
Well,
here's another thing that is a giant issue is that,
uh,
I haven't heard discussed at all mental health.
I mean,
this is really what this is all about.
This is not,
I mean,
this is a gun issue in the sense that he used guns,
but then is it a truck issue in Nice France where that guy just drove into us
people?
I mean,
is it,
uh,
I mean,
there's a ton of different ways to kill people and I'm sure we're going to see
more of these fucked up ways in the future,
but the real issue is a mental health issue.
Now,
this guy's dad was a psychopath.
He was a serial bank robber.
He spent eight years on the FBI's most wanted list.
Here's the question,
right?
Like is that genetic?
Like does that transfer over?
Like how does that work?
It could be genetic or it could be that psychological thing of I want to outdo
my dad.
This,
this guy could be,
I mean,
no,
this guy's a millionaire.
Right.
And so on.
Like,
so he's,
he's a high achiever,
but he could have that whole,
I'm not kidding,
you could have that hole where he always wanted to do something bigger than his
dad or he wanted some approval.
You know what I mean?
Some weird kind of approval thing.
Just speculation,
right?
I mean,
yeah,
I mean you could speculate,
uh,
you know,
a bunch,
our mental health issue,
just the health issue in this country that that's a show unto itself,
right?
We don't,
we don't take care of ourselves.
We don't take care of people.
We don't provide for the mental health,
the mental health problem.
You look downtown in any city in America,
wandering the streets,
homeless,
you got schizophrenia and,
and all kinds of people and you know,
God forbid they got weapons,
you know,
who knows?
Like you talk about the other ways.
I'm sure there are attacks that we just don't hear about.
You know where some guy goes nuts with a knife or a broken bottle or whatever
else,
man,
that's one of the big things that happens in places that have stricter gun
control.
And the argument would be that,
hey,
you know,
that's safer for the people.
It's easier to handle.
There's,
you know,
more things that you can do.
Some guy with a machine gun gunning down all of these people.
But again,
gun control's not really going to help this.
This guy was using illegal guns.
I mean the issue at this point is that there's so many guns out there.
Like even if you make guns illegal,
what are we going to sweep or are we going to go house to house?
And if we do sweep and go house to house,
man,
people are going to resist that because for every one of these psychopaths that
winds up shooting people and,
and,
and gunning someone down,
there's going to be genuine,
normal people that want a gun to protect their family.
Maybe they live in a sketchy neighborhood and then all of a sudden the
government comes along and says,
well now it's illegal for you to possess that gun.
Well then who has guns?
Well,
already criminals.
So yeah,
I think the solution is in between.
And I think this is another one where we get,
you know,
this is a problem we have.
I,
and I can't even say when it started,
when you have the two sides and it's either or.
So it's either,
you know,
no gun regulations or,
or far too many gun regulations.
And I think the solution is somewhere in between.
In my opinion,
it's always been like,
why can't we treat them like cars?
Like when you buy a car,
you registered the car,
right?
So the government knows,
like Joe knows Joe has this car,
right?
And then when you,
you have to have insurance in case something goes wrong with the car and you
hurt somebody.
And then if you sell the car to me,
you tell the government,
hey,
I just sold the car to Alonzo.
I'm no longer liable for this car.
Alonzo's liable for this car.
And I vote.
I've always thought that would be the level of common sense gun,
a registration.
Well here's another one that goes along with that.
With guns you don't really have to know how to use them.
This is where unfortunately fucked up things about,
unfortunately
you drive a car,
you have to take tests,
you have to pass,
you have to understand the registration,
the,
the rules rather.
I mean,
you have to,
you have to go,
a guy has a sit next to you.
We have to go through a driver's test
and I don't see why we can't do that with guns.
You should absolutely.
You have to go to a range and show,
you know,
like the safety of using a gun and,
and how to shoot it.
Yeah,
I don't,
I don't see why we can't do that.
And even if your family teaches you,
right,
they say like in a lot of places you grow up with guns and it's a kid.
Your Dad teaches you.
Well if your dad teaches you to drive,
you still have to go to DMV and take the test.
So it's like your dad,
your mom,
whoever your uncle could teach you to shoot,
but you still,
there should be some,
some level of testing to get an idea.
Cause we have,
you know,
just a couple of weeks ago where you had a four year old in Florida who was
looking in their grandmother's purse for candy and shot themselves.
And it's like that grandma,
there's a safety issue with the gun.
Like you don't tell the kid to go get some candy when you know you have a gun.
I think there's a nutty number,
like 21 people a year are killed in this country by arm.
Toddlers.
Yeah.
I believe it.
Find out what the number is.
I think it's 21 people were shot to death by babies.
Yeah.
Any of the other thing is,
and you brought it up like how,
okay,
if we didn't have guns then they'd be killing,
you know,
with knives or clubs or something like,
just that idea that,
that we have to have that discussion like,
well what weapon at a mass killer is going to use?
That in itself is insane.
Just the fact that we're like,
yeah,
we're going to have these mass killers.
We got to have them working with different weapons.
Uh,
I don't,
I don't know on the mental health I,
I'm not even going to pretend to have the expertise to talk about what it is,
but it's an issue that we don't spend money on.
It's an issue not covered by a lot of insurance.
A lot of insurance doesn't cover any kind of mental health care.
Here's the thing,
even if it does cover mean a giant percentage of the people that commit these
giant mass shootings are either on psychoactive medication or are having
withdrawals from psychoactive medications.
So even if your insurance covers it,
even if you're medicated by a doctor,
there's like,
there's a disassociated quality apparently with a lot of these antidepressants
and anti psychotic medications that people take that with the right combination
of biology,
circumstances,
genetics,
whatever it is.
People just can snap and they don't have an issue.
I mean,
what,
what are the numbers of people that are on that stuff?
A giant number,
right?
What are the numbers of people that actually wind up and go and do shootings?
Much,
much,
much smaller number.
But it's enough that if it happens once a year,
like Orlando last year and then this year in Vegas,
I mean what the Fuck Nigga again,
we don't know why this guy did this.
We will have no idea if he was on anything.
But what the fuck is it that we have to do to stop this stuff from happening?
Well,
I mean,
I'm sure there were scientists who study it and all,
but I can't imagine people look at,
you can predict it.
People getting shot got
by toddlers on a basis this year cause Jesus Christ.
How many people have killed themselves?
18 more injured themselves,
10 injured other people to kill the other people.
That was from 2015
toddlers have killed at least shot at least 23 people this year.
Jesus fucking Christ.
Five months.
Oh my God.
Okay,
so we can't,
we cannot match that with no argument of toddler drivers having run over people.
No.
Well,
irresponsible gun owners.
That is.
And,
and again,
that gets back to what you're saying,
the education,
like learn to own a gun safely to keep it somewhere where a toddler's not going
to get to it.
I have something,
everything dangerous safely,
everything.
And isn't it funny how,
you know,
we do kid proof a house,
like,
like you know,
they have some plastic things that go into the electrical sockets and the poison
initially that,
what about the gun?
Hey,
throw it in the candy drawer,
put it under your pillow.
Kid's never going to get there.
Yeah,
I mean there,
there's a lot of responsibility.
I don't mean to laugh,
but I mean I'm laughing at the ridiculous of it and that,
and that is true.
And I think the vast majority of gun owners are,
are um,
responsible.
You know,
it is another group that's painted with the broad brush,
right?
That th the few gun nuts crazy what they paint every NRA member as being one of
them.
And that isn't true.
You know,
like I said,
I know,
I know people,
people who like guns and they're not that.
But the people who are not,
that have to accept the fact that there is a population that is that,
you know what I mean?
You,
you can't say that they don't exist because they do exist.
So I big part of this,
I think like any other issue,
Joe,
we got to start telling each other the truth.
You know what I mean?
About about these issues.
Like we,
everyone has their,
their side,
right?
Or their tribe or their team and they refuse to believe any truth and you know,
any,
any negative truth about their team or whatever,
you know what I mean?
Like,
like,
like to say,
well,
like we were saying like gun owners.
Okay,
so there's responsible gun owners and then there's a few gun blog and just use
the term gun nuts.
And a responsible gun owners have to accept the fact that there was some gun
nuts,
right.
With the police.
The vast majority of police are good,
but the good police have to say he had,
there were some bad cops too.
Right.
You know what I mean?
Like,
like within any,
within it,
any trial were comics.
We know there was some bad comics.
I don't know if you know a joke,
but I'm going to put it out there.
I heard of a family.
But,
but until we,
until we do that,
we can never have a real discussion,
right.
Because everybody just suddenly circles the wagons around their heard and like,
no,
nothing.
You know,
it's like,
no,
we're not saying all of you are bad,
but let's admit within your group there is bad.
So we can work on that.
Yeah.
I've seen some tweets from some,
a NRA supporters the last day and a half that are just fucking stunned me where
it just shut the fuck up,
man.
Just re realize what the state of all this is right now and shut the fuck up.
And by the way,
there's a video that's going around that somebody put up about me talking about
gun control is not a recent video.
I don't know when it's from,
but people are putting it up now,
uh,
about me,
destroying the gun control argument.
Uh,
it's,
it would be very insensitive for me to do that and put that up right now.
And I didn't,
it had nothing to do with,
I don't know when it was,
I don't know.
I think it was from a year or so ago,
but,
but the idea that these people,
these NRA supporters would go and tweet these pro gun messages and get crazy
with it now is exactly what you're saying.
They're digging their heels in.
They're supporting their team.
Yeah.
And,
and as many people have been saying and,
and it is a sad truth.
Look,
if we didn't wake up after Sandy Hook,
then you know,
if,
when 20,
what was it,
21 kids were shot.
Yeah.
That and people denied that it happened to,
oh,
that didn't even happen at all.
That,
you know what I mean?
People are calling this a false flag.
Right.
So,
so if that didn't wake us up,
yeah.
Then you know,
58 people at a music concert,
I hate to say it,
but it's like,
it's not going to wake us up.
You know,
I have,
I have a thing waking stop.
Mean,
you know,
I mean wake us up to the point of take some action,
but what's the other thing?
A lot of precedent.
Alonzo,
what would you do the,
the um,
well to start with,
we have to have the conversation.
We have to have the conversation about,
they're just like we touched,
talked about there isn't a necessary we,
it is necessary to change our gun laws are gun laws are too lax.
That's the first thing.
Then what we need to do,
we need to come up with a system just like we have with cars or anything else
dangerous where you,
you have to be trained to use it.
You have to register whatever it is with the government and you have to have
liability insurance and it,
and that,
that information transfers.
Like the big loophole is the gun shows,
right?
Where you go to the gun show and you could just sell a gun to another person.
You can do that with all the case.
Yeah.
And a lot of states,
that's still the case.
You can do that with a car,
right?
I can sell you my car through craigslist,
but I'm still going to go put it in that a liability thing.
Otherwise I'm liable for what you do with the car.
Like I protect myself by reporting it even though I sold it to you party the
party.
Yeah.
So,
so it,
yeah,
if I'm in charge,
we're going to,
we're going to add those things.
We're going to get,
we're going to get a handle on these guns were going to get start tracking how
many they are,
where they are.
We're going to collect them.
Um,
I think it was Australia and some other places that had those things where,
look Australia,
if you own an illegal weapon,
like a fully automatic weapon or whatever makes it illegal,
you can turn it in.
Maybe there's payment or maybe it's just no questions asked.
Just turn it in and we'll,
we'll destroy it.
Well,
what happened in Australia is they had a mass shooting and then they put their
foot down and they said,
no mark,
I'll show you.
Just banned them all together.
Totally ban them.
You can still use a rifle to hunt.
But,
um,
the way we have this sort of fast and loose po,
there's very few countries in the world that have this kind of fast and loose
gun policy.
I think.
Yeah,
we still have the wild west mentality.
Well,
anybody have freedom mentality,
which you bill Riley did a fucking had a post today where he's talking about
that this is the cost of car.
The freedom.
Yeah.
Fucking crazy.
No,
it's not.
Oh,
it's crazy old dickhead.
And I'll give you an example,
Joe.
Like I grew up in New York City.
Like guns had been illegal in New York City for a long time.
Now there are guns in New York City,
but not as many as people think,
you know,
because what happens is when you make it illegal,
then the average person,
they don't go out of their way to get a gun.
They're like,
no,
I'm not.
I'm not going to have one.
Yeah,
a criminal is going to have guns.
Yas Criminals are always going to have guns.
But you know the thing about the good guy shooting the bad guy,
it doesn't happen that often.
And my personal belief on this is because in that moment it takes a lot to shoot
somebody.
It just happened the other day.
They just happened the other day and it was just saying that should happen.
There was an active shooter somewhere that was taken out by a,
a good guy got on her.
It can happen.
You're right.
It doesn't happen everywhere all the time,
but it can happen in a lot of people get their guns stolen or taken away because
in that moment they can't use it.
Sure.
And the criminal,
he ain't got nothing to lose.
He's already a criminal,
you know what I mean?
Also probably used to violence.
Yeah.
A lot of people are not used to violence.
There's a lot of soft people out there that just,
they don't know what to do if the shit hits the fan in any way,
shape,
or form.
I just don't know how to handle pressure.
Yeah.
And,
and it's,
you know,
that happens in the Nate,
so they buy a gun to protect themselves,
but they're in no way equipped to use it.
Yeah.
Well,
there's a lot of that.
They're hoping that they can use it or to scare people off or something like
that.
But most likely,
yeah,
they're not going to be able to do it.
But you know,
then there's people that say,
well that's them.
I want the option because I will be able to figure it out.
You know,
because I'm not a pussy or I'm not.
Then there's a legal way to get one.
You know,
you do what it takes to and you register it.
And again,
most gun owners that I know,
and I may be wrong cause it's not like I'm deep in the gun culture,
so I'm not speaking with that expertise.
I'm just talking about of the people I know who have guns who are into guns and
shooting.
I only have one friend who's like doesn't want to register his guns or or
anything like that.
Most of them I know they're fine with having their gun residue.
One friend's argument,
I couldn't even tell you.
I honestly couldn't it.
I love him,
I love him.
But it's crazy when it comes to guns.
He's got a little,
he's got some of that paranoia.
He's got some of that.
The government's out to get me government.
Her.
No,
and then you know,
his thing with,
um,
we were talking about,
and I know it's the wrong term,
but it's the common term assault weapons,
assault type weapons.
Right.
And he said like,
yeah,
well what if there's a home invasion?
That's what they use.
And now it's like,
hey,
nobody invading your broke ass home.
You Ain't getting,
you still want to get your guns.
You know what I mean?
You got,
you got,
you know,
you had average American would a two bedroom in the suburbs.
Ain't nobody invading your shit.
Right.
You ain't got a safe,
if you selling crack,
you might want to worry,
you might have some cash around the house,
even if you were a good marijuana distributed,
it'd be a bunch of cash.
You're not allowed to put in the bank,
but you ain't nobody invading your house.
Yeah.
Everybody wants to be John Wick.
Okay.